o que nós vemos quando olhamos um gari
recolhendo o nosso lixo será que
percebemos a diferença entre eles e o
lixo que coleta
imaginemos essa nossa bela cidade cheia
de encantos naturais sem a ação do gari
eles são heróis invisíveis não é mesmo
garis são homens e mulheres anônimos que
passam dias nas ruas recolhendo
recolhendo lixos catando entulhos sempre
de cabeça baixa compenetrados eles
enfrentam cães ferozes correm risco de
serem contaminados por resíduos
descartados de forma errada mas eles são
seres humanos não é mesmo
foi então que eu tive um sonho um sonho
de ré significa vida do gari
quando me formei em psicologia que iria
humanizar e valorizar a vida deles fazer
algo para mudar essa situação
longos anos se passaram e esse sonho se
tornou realidade
em 2005 o primeiro passo foi dado nessa
direção em viagens a outros estados e
municípios
vi que alguns avanços aconteciam
referentes a essa questão então mudamos
a forma de chamar o gari
ele agora era o agente de limpeza urbana
depois criei implementei o setor
psicossocial danilo que a autarquia
especial municipal de limpeza urbana
órgão responsável pela limpeza da cidade
um processo que durou nove meses
foi na gestação demorou mas nasceu
enquanto esses meses se passavam algumas
poucas atividades conseguimos realizar
iremos até eles e só depois na nossa
sede é que demos início às atividades
ali programadas que foi acolher dentro
da rede municipal de saúde de atenção
básica o agente de limpeza e
necessitasse de ajuda e que pudesse ser
reabilitado uma porta se abriu naquele
momento para aqueles que nem sequer
tinham como gritar pois eram invisíveis
desde então estou em dedicação exclusiva
é importante ressaltar o salto que demos
na promoção de mudança de comportamento
ao acolher o agente de limpeza cada dia
que sentimos a cada atendimento o peso
que cada um trazia sobre seus corpos
cada sorriso não dado cada frase
completada com muita dificuldade
enquanto participávamos entrávamos na
vida deles mas eles percebiam a
importância daquele momento dedicado
para cada atendimento
percebemos claramente que eles começaram
a olhar para si a se autoconhecer e
neste processo a autoestima deles era
recuperada
enquanto ajudava a mudar a vida deles
mudava a minha também
o setor psicossocial danilo é
responsável pelo acolhimento e o
atendimento e avaliação e avaliação
psicológica do agente de limpeza urbana
também encaminhamentos para centros de
atenção psicossocial que tratam a droga
eo álcool no município e no estado
encaminhamentos
para consultas clínica médica
psiquiatria e neurologia
quando o agente de limpeza não tem
condições de ir até nós por conta de
alguma internação hospitalar
o problemas físicos vamos até eles
através das visitas hospitalares e
domiciliares
formamos grupos para aqueles agentes que
estão há três anos para aposentação
através de reuniões mensais de
conscientização e sensibilização de que
a aposentadoria não é a morte mas sim
mas na etapa de vida
hoje foram inseridos esposos e esposas e
seus filhos e filhos abaixo de 10 anos
de idade também estão sendo atendidos
pelo setor e agora quero me referir ao
que considero a atividade mais
importante realizada pelo setor que é o
acolhimento na tentativa de reabilitar o
agente de limpeza que está com problemas
ligados ao álcool ea droga
criamos um grupo de ajuda mútua onde
neste grupo são reunidos semanalmente em
e temos palestras com médicos psicólogos
e educadores reuniões onde tratam
exclusivamente da dependência também são
trocados relatos e depoimentos dos
agentes que estão em recuperação
ainda fazemos encaminhamentos para
outras unidades de saúde a fim de conter
surtos ocasionados pelo uso abusivo do
álcool e da droga e sua desintoxicação
posterior e neste universo de tantos
agentes que já foram acolhidos
lembro especialmente de uma história
um certo dia recebemos no nosso setor
um agente que aqui vou chamar de joão e
joão tinha muitos problemas de saúde e
muitos problemas de ordem psicológica
joão chegou extremamente debilitado
muito magrinho com sérias complicações
de saúde
joão estava pra ser demitido por conta
do número de faltas
joão tinha muitas dificuldades e
conflitos nas relações de trabalho e nas
relações pessoais mas joão tenha muitos
talentos só não conseguisse pressa
porque ele estava vivendo o drama da
dependência
pouco a pouco a cada escuta a cada
orientação joão foi começando a
compreender o contexto que ele estava
inserido
ele começou a melhorar sua vida
profissional e pessoal e para nossa
alegria hoje joão faz parte do projeto
catadores de arte que leva a mensagem da
educação ambiental para órgãos escolas
públicas e privadas através da música e
do teatro joão está afastado das drogas
continua em recuperação e não falta mas
eu trabalho como joão
temos muitas outras histórias o psico
social do ano do seu nascimento até a
presente data acolheu e tratou entre
seus agentes e seus familiares 536
pessoas que tiveram suas vidas
modificadas
quero neste momento agradecer a
oportunidade de mostrar que uma simples
atitude pode transformar vidas e sejamos
todos nós agentes de ressignificado
humano
boa tarde